amid the scandival that rocked the world
Raquel Levis has checked into a mental
health treatment facility Raquel's rep
tells ET that she decided to enter a
voluntary facility for mental health
counseling before her relationship with
Tom Sandoval was discovered in March a
romance that went on for months behind
closed doors all while Tom was in a
nine-year relationship with Ariana
Maddox open relationships this is a
full-blown love affair I wish we both
would have tried harder you don't
deserve one Frontier of mine Raquel's
rep says she actually planned to admit
herself ahead of the Vanderpump Rules
reunion which was taped on March 23rd
but she wanted to finish her filming
commitment there was just so much on the
table that needed to be and everyone had
things to say the rep adds that Bravo in
production were aware and are in support
of Raquel's Journey towards better
mental health they also note Raquel's
not in rehab for substance abuse issues
since the cheating scandal broke the
pump rules cast past and present hasn't
shied away from sharing their feelings
the fact that she had not a single tear
No Remorse she sat at the reunion and
did not shed one tear no I know she
actually smiled having to live this
publicly and then like being so
embarrassed by it and like having to go
through it like I I just feel so bad for
Ariana having to go through this so
publicly he's been with Ariana for
almost 10 years and you know best
friends with Raquel so it's like he's
this was this is like a whole on
relationship this isn't just a hooked up
with somebody in this and I'm sorry I
didn't go back this is the relationship
there's lack of empathy there it was
like a premeditated situation you want
anything for you to die I've now done
hundreds of reunions so yeah I would say
this is going to be this is going to be
top ten
[Music]
thank you